[Music]
it's impossible to spend time with
animals and not walk away feeling that
something else is going on in there I'm
very passionate about trying to tell a
story about animal intelligence so this
assignment with National Geographic on
avalanche dogs was a wonderful
opportunity to ignite this larger
project that I have in my mind
[Music]
I'm a National Geographic photographer
[Music]
I'm here in Bozeman Montana to try and
tell story about a man named Graham and
his avalanche rescue dog Erna
what really pulled me into this
assignment and the angle that I was
coming from is animal intelligence so
what I'm really trying to do is to tell
a story that shows that dogs are
thinking sentient beings and so to
convey that erna is out there thinking
about her job every time I take a step I
fall down up to my knee
people think the lives of photographers
are idyllic romantic even and that you
just go out there and the photos flow
like wine but the reality is that
there's a lot of stuff that you're
dealing with there are a few instances
where we're having to trek through snow
to get to other places where you
couldn't ski so it was like 15 degrees
so that makes everything harder you know
even the best cameras aren't built for
these conditions I'm not a huge skier
your hands freezing waist-deep in snow
but $40,000 camera gear on your back I'm
thinking to myself every picture I'm
trying to take everything everything is
against me and I have you know a couple
of days to pull this off what do you got
a lot of times images we want to get end
up coming to fruition in the field in
the moment I saw Emily Graham's wife
getting buried and that that's when I
knew that that was the picture I thought
you know why don't I get in there
because I could show what it's like to
be rescued by a dog all right so I'm
gonna have enough oxygen down there just
fine all right
I mean the challenge of getting that
shot you're in a teeny little hole and
you you're kind of having to contort
yourself and I'm not in those flexible
person a look on her face you know that
she's thinking about one thing and
that's about getting me out and then the
challenge was that as she was digging
snow was falling on top of me like every
five seconds I was having to their white
nail off the front of the lens and then
take a picture my gut said I was soaked
good you know I think if you were
seriously buried an avalanche you can
imagine the feeling that you must be
having when you see her a retriever
digging the hole open and saving your
life I mean it's got to be a moment
[Music]
you always don't think that you've got
the shot and there's a saying that if
you think you've got the shot then you
don't and so you always have this worry
did I get the picture did I get the
picture and when you get a photo that
you're happy with it's it's like
Christmas
what I'm thinking about all the time is
what a gram and Erna doing that is
special and what do I think is important
to tell they're out there saving
people's lives every single day
[Music]